the matterwords the metaverse metabolos
everyone in tech is talking about these
new virtual worlds where people will be
able to do plenty of things work learn
play shop but many years before them a
man had already created an online world
that was also advertised as a place to
work play learn and shop second life is
in many ways the only kind of real
metaverse sort of experience that yet
exists at least especially for grownups
that's philip rosedale the founder of
second life and this is his avatar in
the game
yes remember the world you'd enter from
your windows xp desktop in 2003
it had its own virtual economy and some
people even said they made millions of
dollars trading in it
over the years interest in the platform
waned but second life now sees an
opportunity to stage a comeback
rosedale's returning to the world he
created 13 years after leaving the
company to be a strategic advisor his
plan is to improve the platform's
experience without the use of vr
headsets and to make it work better on
smartphones if you looked aspirationally
at what people could do with a metaverse
second life
in many ways is still the one to watch
and even the one to beat
so we look at second life's vision and
why its past struggles can serve as a
lesson for virtual worlds of the future
rosedale began developing second life in
1999 as he toured with how to escape his
own reality and to see how far he could
push his technical expertise
this is what an early version of the
game looked like
i
you know certainly was looking asking
myself the question of whether i could
just build a whole other world and
disappear into it rosedale's goal was to
make this virtual world seen here in
2003 look as lifelike as possible as
well as being free from the limits of
reality part of that was giving users
the power to shape the digital realm
they immediately
bought the land from underneath all the
things we had built and tore them all
down you know to create their own vision
of what they wanted the place to be
the game's virtual economy digital
tokens called linden dollars that can be
exchanged for us dollars allows members
to earn while playing the game
some forge careers as virtual real
estate barons we're definitely pioneers
at second life in identifying
that that sort of
right to take things you'd made with
your hands you know in in a virtual
space
and own them and sell them to other
people freely in 2007 second life had
some one million active monthly users
and even featured in television shows
in my second life i was also a paper
salesman absolutely everything was the
same
except i could fly but by 2019 second
life reported had lost a quarter of its
monthly users
re-entering the world today can help us
understand why
it's complicated to use creating an
avatar involves using sliders that can
change the shape of each part of the
body trying to change clothes requires
multiple steps and brings you to a
separate marketplace
it's also glitchy in some areas items
take minutes to load and it can be hard
to find people to interact with the
interface is difficult
tech giants like meta formerly known as
facebook have shared visions of a
metaverse operating in a completely new
internet environment allowing users to
move assets between different networks
secondlife says this platform still has
potential and is betting on an immediate
refresh starting with trying to
streamline this interface and make it
more accessible on smartphones it
currently doesn't have an official app
in the apple store or google play
secondlife says one of its strengths is
that avatars offer more customization
options than other competitors for
example the gaming platform roblox which
is also developing metaverse concepts
and horizon by meta
for rosedale continuing to enhance the
already realistic figures is key for the
platform to stand out i like to focus on
this idea of like how do i wiggle my
hands when i talk to you in the
metaverse you know how do i how do we
feel visually connected to each other
and i think that work can be done
without vr headsets while meta has made
vr and ar devices an integral part of
its vision for the metaverse the creator
of second life believes webcams could be
used to help simulate more authentic
character movements
when it comes to audience second life is
not on the same scale as its competitors
meta's facebook instagram and other
services have 3.5 billion monthly users
combined and the two companies don't
have the same resources either
secondlife has said it's investing
millions in improving the platform meta
said its initial spending on the project
is around 10 billion dollars
second life has survived over the years
because of a smaller group of loyal
members and says it makes money by
taking a commission on the sales of
their creations
the company said the total volume of
sales and transactions in its virtual
world was worth 650 million dollars
while tech giants say the metaverse is
set to be a massive global industry
rosedale's skeptical that any company
will be able to keep large audiences
interested in these virtual platforms
most of us who have
a comfortable existence in our real
bodies in the real world
are going to still tend to prefer that
virtual worlds are a
choice that you have to make
and it's a very uh substantial and
considerate
you know choice and it's not necessarily
something that all of us are going to
want to do